les grands ensembles
dans les années 1950 alors que la grande
majorité des réunionnais vivent encore
dans des cases en paille
la sdr société immobilière du
département de la réunion jette les
bases du logement social dans l'île
elle innove en proposant des logements
en dur à loyer modéré
les premiers logements sociaux sont
constitués de maisons individuelles
jumelées ou en bande dans l'architecturé
en rupture totale avec le style créole
traditionnels
au cours des années 1960 1970 la
population augmente considérablement
de nombreux réunionnais qui te les
écarts en direction des pôles urbains où
ils s'installent dans des conditions
précaires les bidonvilles se multiplient
il s'agit d'aller vite pour offrir un
logement décent aux plus grands murs
c'est ainsi compte deux décennies les
champs tour en les villes se transforme
en une multitude de quartiers urbains
dominé par des immeubles
ces grands ensembles sont des réponses
faites dans l'urgence à une situation de
crise ils sont aussi le fruit d'une
industrialisation progressive du secteur
du bâtiment et des procédés de
préfabrication en béton ces villes
nouvelles ou ses nouveaux quartiers
périphériques forme et aujourd'hui des
ensembles architecturaux important dans
lesquelles vivent de plus en plus de
réunionnais pour nombre d'entre eux
l'immeuble constitue inconsciemment une
référence patrimonial qui doit être
prise en compte dans l'histoire de
l'habitat à la réunion